i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 donde analizamos la
actualidad de la copa américa y la
eurocopa a continuación nuestros
titulares
chequeen retumbo en wembley inglaterra
derrota a alemania en los octavos de
final y olvida la eliminación de la euro
de 1996 a manos de los hermanos el
encuentro marcó el final de king lok al
frente de la selección alemana tras 15
años tenemos análisis y reacciones
histórico la selección de ucrania que
está en su tercera participación en una
euro logró avanzar por primera vez a los
cuartos de final al derrotar a suecia
con marcador de 2 goles por 1 ahora
enfrentarán a los 3 leones en cuartos
con la mente de alcanzar una inédita
semifinal
américa o europa donde se juega el mejor
fútbol la eurocopa ha dejado jornadas
interesantes mientras la copa américa
sigue en deuda con la afición analizamos
ambos torneos y ponemos el foco en las
posibles diferencias que presentan ambos
continentes en la actualidad
como ya es habitual en cada una de
nuestras emisiones contamos con la
presencia de sara castro directora del
diario 'as' colombia bienvenidas ahora
como estas como siempre un gusto y ya
llegamos a cuartos de final entonces se
va poniendo mejor la cosa dicen que
empieza cada vez un nuevo torneo hace 25
años
londres recibía la semifinal de la euro
entre inglaterra y alemania el partido
al igual que seis años antes como lo
pueden el mundial de italia en 1990
quedaría impactado en el tiempo
reglamentario más la prórroga provocando
disparos desde el punto penal donde en
ambas ocasiones se impuso alemania ayer
wembley recibía el partido de octavos
entre estas dos escuadras pero la sombra
de lo ocurrido en 1996 estaba presente
más cuando en aquel entonces el único
penal fallado fue por el técnico de la
selección inglesa la historia en esta
ocasión fue distinta y los ingleses se
impusieron con marcador de 2 goles por 0
gracias a las anotaciones de raheem
sterling y harry caine
a parte del conjunto inglés sarah que
hizo gareth southgate para cambiar la
mentalidad de los jugadores ingleses y
provocar este resultado positivo para
inglaterra lo primero que es muy
interesante es que además de pelear
contra esos fantasmas del pasado por
esas esos enfrentamientos históricos
entre inglaterra y alemania también es
inglaterra ha tenido que jugar con la
responsabilidad de ser candidato y eso
es difícil ahora ayer en alemania
arrancó muy bien los dos primeros
tiempos pero sus jugadores sus muy
buenos jugadores no han estado al nivel
para generar esa diferencia
shalit fue cuestionado sobre todo por
los nombres que dejó en el banco cuando
enfocaba en el banco parecía que algo
estaba mal sin embargo hay que ver y es
muy revelador ver a un jugador como saca
19 años generando le problemas a
alemania y luego cuando entra grizzlies
y cambia el partido cambió el partido
porque estaba siempre donde tenía que
estar y eso hizo que está inglaterra
fuera eficiente al final south gate
entre cuestionamientos o no joseba con
una valla invicta en 4
ya están cuartos de final y además tiene
jugando bien al equipo y clasifica con
un gol de sterling que además ya tiene
tres en esta eurocopa un niño que pasaba
siempre por wembley y lo veía a lo lejos
entonces creo que se cierra este círculo
histórico ahora inglaterra
viaja roma y ante ucrania ahora sí que
se pone como favorito a llevarse esta
eurocopa por supuesto que sí pero vamos
a escuchar qué fue lo que dijo el
técnico inglés al concluir ese encuentro
final después que estos jugadores siguen
escribiendo la historia y tienen una
oportunidad para hacerlo de nuevo lo
saben sólo hemos llegado a semifinales
en un campeonato de europa
wissam singh otra vez ellos tienen la
oportunidad de hacer algo realmente
especial jones de verdad previo a la
eurocopa el seleccionador alemán team le
anunció que se retiraría por lo que ayer
habría estado al frente del banquillo
germano por última vez
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo el día de
hoy el ahora técnico saliente de
alemania
y se tomará un poco de tiempo aceptar
esta decepción creo que han sido 15 años
muy largos para mí con muchos momentos
hermosos y por supuesto también con
decepciones creo que este equipo y
algunos de los jugadores que sin duda
estarán con nosotros durante los
próximos años realmente tienen un futuro
muy muy bueno por delante y quizás
también logren el éxito que todos
deseando escuchar por supuesto también
le deseo a mi sucesor hansi flick todo
lo mejor y mucho éxito mi corazón sigue
latiendo negro rojo y dorado gold
hay algo que recriminarle inglés en
estos 15 años al frente de la selección
alemana yo creo que esto es muy
interesante porque es que no sólo
hablamos de leds sino hablamos de el
proyecto del fútbol alemán después de
que alemania cae muy mal en esa eurocopa
del 2000 lo que hace la federación es
decir necesitamos un proyecto para
entender a qué jugamos y eso va a ser
fundamental cuando hablemos luego
también del fútbol sudamericano y ellos
lo que hacen es que empiezan a entrenar
entrenadores que pareciera que
redundante pero no lo es es prepararlos
para la selección de talentos y sobre
todo definir cuál va a ser ese adn cuál
es ser van a ser las características del
juego que van a hacer que podamos
imponernos a futuro
todos los proyectos tienen altos y bajos
creo que evidentemente lo del mundial de
2014 pues le da todo el crédito al des
pero además deja una construcción lo que
sí hay que tener claro es que una cosa
es el proyecto y otra cosa los procesos
los procesos y se terminan y con esta
nueva generación de jugadores de pronto
la metodología y el mensaje tendría que
cambiar yo creo que lo que viene
conflicto va a ser muy interesante va a
continuar lo que ya se ha venido
trabajando pero por supuesto dándole
también un aire nuevo 15 años pesan para
cualquier trabajador en cualquier
empresa rápidamente revisamos que logró
este test seleccionador al frente de su
equipo 198 partidos desde el año 2006
124 victorias 2 subtítulos de renombre
uno de ellos la copa del mundo en 2014
en brasil y la copa confederaciones en
el año 2017
por otro lado en otro compromiso la
selección de ucrania necesitó de poco
más de 120 minutos para derrotar a
suecia dos goles por uno y con ello
avanzar a los cuartos de final del
torneo es la tercera vez que ucrania
participe en una eurocopa y la primera
vez que logra trascender la fase de
grupos escuchemos lo que dijo alexander
sin 5 mediocampista del conjunto
ucraniano de estrenos que nos dieron un
plan y todos merecíamos esta victoria
logramos concretar todas las ideas que
teníamos esto no es el final
tenemos que pensar en el próximo partido
contra el rival más peligroso que
tenemos una misma noche estadi seria
considerando que es uno de los equipos
más fuertes del mundo
intentaremos hacer todo lo posible para
obtener el resultado que necesitamos
para pasar del bridge no es ni resultado
y proyecto de estadio sabrá qué mérito
tiene andriy shevchenko al frente de
este equipo lo toma en 2016 ya lo lleva
a cuartos de final y que debe hacer
ahora para enfrentar a inglaterra hablar
de chips en que es hablar de ucrania y
sobre todo para mi generación por
ejemplo es un jugador que marcó una
época y creo que eso se ve reflejado en
la idea de juego que en planta pero
sobre todo en la convicción que generan
sus jugadores ese plan del que hablaba
el jugador tiene que ver con una manera
de competir que si bien no hay los
mismos talentos que en otros equipos
si hay una estrategia clara seguir de
todas formas ya que hablamos de
decepción como ahora hablamos de
xincheng code malinovski y de yarmólenko
es decir también hay talento en este
equipo y poder desequilibrar por
supuesto la prórroga a suecia le costó
mucho por el hombre menos y ahí se
cuidaron mucho y bueno ahora hay que
decir que le había pasado tercera del
grupo
y suecia llegado invicta esto habla
mucho del espíritu que tiene este equipo
para competir en la siguiente ronda
rápidamente revisamos los partidos de
cuartos de final además de este gran
inglaterra bélgica estará midiéndose a
italia españa a suiza y república checa
dinamarca recientemente el jugador belga
thomas mini
integrantes del seleccionado de este
país expresó que ganar la eurocopa era
mejor que ganar la copa del mundo y que
con excepción de brasil los mejores
equipos estaban en este continente
sus declaraciones aumentan un debate que
ha surgido en los últimos años respecto
al nivel de las elecciones de europa en
comparación con las que pertenecen a la
conmebol
sara ha sido un debate recurrente en los
últimos años sobre todo el nivel
mostrado pero los resultados están allí
su americano gana desde el 2002 un
título mundial y las últimas copas
confederaciones también ha estado en
manos europeos por supuesto que preocupa
y es evidente en la diferencia de
niveles más allá de hablar del
calendario porque en esta copa américa
nos encontramos con equipos uno que
iniciaban procesos y que no se reunían
hacía mucho tiempo creo que la copa
américa del 2019 incluso tuvo un mejor
nivel hay que hablar muchísimo de la
estructura este es un mercado exportador
que como tal tiene que reconocerse en
general hablando de sudamérica vendemos
jugadores muy jóvenes y luego esa idea
del juego que estaba muy vinculada a la
creatividad al potrero evidentemente se
ha visto afectada por las condiciones
del fútbol actual se trata de estructura
hace unos días hablábamos aquí con
federico de las canchas de los campos de
juego pero tiene que ver con eso con una
decisión de que vamos a jugar y cómo
vamos a generar una estructura que
incluso tiene que ver con el mercadeo y
demás para que esto sea sostenible es
evidente que el nivel es diferente pero
tampoco tenemos cómo compararnos o como
decir que esto no es fútbol no aquí
también hay un relato cultural
importante también hay unas condiciones
de juego que son totalmente diferentes
jugar en sudamérica implica además
logísticamente retos para los
entrenadores y esto nos lleva a hacer
análisis más profundos sobre todo de
cara a la conmebol y por supuesto a cada
una de las federaciones que tiene que
empezar a dar la pelea a encontrar sdn y
ese punto diferencial que ya no se queda
simplemente en qué
jugadores talentosos
ya la conmebol o la copa américa se
acerca a lo que es la etapa de
definición definición de los cuartos de
final y comenzarán el día viernes en
este caso brasil estará enfrentando a
chile perú estará midiéndose a la
representación de paraguay argentina
hará lo propio frente a ecuador y
uruguay estará midiéndose a colombia
de esta manera llegamos al final del
diario de copas por el día de hoy
continúen con más de la programación de
france 24 y france 24 puntocom